foreign
what wait
I was trying
I did it huh
is this gonna be important is this going
to be on the test
[Music]
okay really keep the cursor over the
cyan field okay
[Music]
okay calibration complete I don't know
what I calibrated well I haven't even
played the game yet
I don't know if that was important but
hello and welcome to input six some game
about a robo Maiden that's all I saw and
that was enough for me to buy it
we're gonna play
shift to fast forward
what
high for space to change input to avoid
malfunctioning robot
input
what what what what is this
highlight with interactive
[Music]
am I playing or am I watching okay was
to move apparently shift to fast forward
E to highlight interacted objects
control left mouth button configuration
event action and space to change input
map section space
oh new record added to archives dear
employees due to the recent events of
the morning of April 18 1994 the
management decided to close all
companies facilities until further
notice henceforth you fired all workers
will be compensated for non-working days
except the days that you didn't work and
never the days that you won't ever not
work thanks to the correctly conducted
emergency evacuation proceeds as all
employees left the company's main
building safely nobody was hurt the
reason for the alarm going off is not
yet known to ensure future work safety
the management decided to conduct an
inspection of all the company's
facilities by our specialized Department
under the sister company addressed
Industries please remain calm and wait
for further information on the reopening
of the company sincerely this is weird
there was an incident that was bad
enough to literally close the company
for the foreseeable future
or whatever
I guess they didn't expect it to be very
long
I'm supposed to avoid you get out of my
face
oh I am playing
interesting
oh no I'm not gonna like this game am I
oh we in mannequin
[Music]
why
we in mannequin down apparently I don't
know what I'm supposed to be there I've
got a timer wait I don't know why did
you wait a minute
I've got a crack in my brain what is
happening
well I'm skiing
all right it's a little too early for me
to be uh
confused
who's making noise over there
huh is this just uh that incident that I
heard so much about that I'm not afraid
of uh you ain't gonna scare me
see I don't know what the noises mean
yet but I know that I am a big Brave boy
Brave man
chest hair and such well maybe not that
but oh no
not important
why
what am I doing
oh no
oh
I did it why is it red
it's a red
I'm fast forwarding somehow
that's my Sprint
I fast forward
should I should I be worried about what
happened to the other oh my God
oh my god well I don't know where she
came from I'm pretty sure she wasn't
there before but
am I supposed to be worried about those
noises because I'm not
One's Gonna Be Brave
you Slenderman ass
made
be gone made
I don't know what happened
what the hell is happening oh no it's
signal
I better do something about that uh oh
oh well that's I'm colorblind now
hey
probably not good
probably not why
well I'm back
everything's good nothing needed to be
worrying me at all in the first place
it's a good thing my vision is
immediately drawn to you
I'm not gonna fall for that one
I don't know if I'm falling for anything
but as soon as I hear those footsteps
I'm not about that I I haven't died yet
and I can only assume that my actions
have prevented me from suffering of such
a fate that would be so heinous that I
and I remember remember Elixir and make
it sound like I'm saying something
intelligent I don't know what to say so
I asked my Portuguese Editor to come up
with something clever to put here that's
real smart I'm so big brain just listen
to my clever words
I realize what I'm doing now is this
Elixir and do the let's play for me come
up with something
I am one step closer to building an AI
model to replicate me in full wow God
man this is
I did it
holy crap I did it
man I'm not gonna be good at doing that
in the future and also I still don't
know what the hell I'm looking for
didn't give me any idea what I'm
supposed to get but I'm on it boss I
guess nope
why is this one the scary one
I'm gonna go up the stairs oh no I'm not
no I'm not beep beep why beep what beep
who's tinkling
hey
hey get out of there we're supposed to
be evacuated
this wasn't open before was it
nice
probably bad
man it gets me every time
oh
okay I I feel like every time I'm
wandering into a new area but I still
don't see what I'm going for
[Music]
oh boy well that well
oh hey oh wow new wreck occurred
is that dead now is that a dead one now
no I'm
you okay why is there an even faster
count down here
oh I can't move this camera uh
fascinating
okay well um uh is if that's the only
one that means I got time
I got another time on my hands what am I
looking at hands I see a hand
oh wrench
mayhaps I could use it to defend myself
from the evil robot
this is a new place again I keep going
to new places how do I keep finding new
places
I thought well I'm not gonna stay on
that one I thought I would have had my
bearings by now but I do not
stop
no this is wait is this familiar weapon
here
no idea
not a well not a clue
and see it's like my short-term memory
has got to work whoa oh I gotta remember
where I last was before I
appeared somewhere else oh boy
I'm amazing
yeah because I definitely ain't seen no
cafeteria before
but there might be something good
good hello good
okay I'm back here
none of this is familiar I've got no
bearings
is this really good at mixing me up nope
don't trust that ah but I do remember
this now
okay oh fast forwarding has been
disabled
that's not good
oh boy
so if I look at yeah oh I'm in the pile
of scrab now okay I see I see how it is
foreign
man
yes
okay but I just went in a circle this is
not helpful wait I'm fast forwarding
you can't stop me
come on how many problems can I have
foreign
that one's no good that one's a no-go
man or input three here well I've been
run through the ringer
God I've been here before
I can't go upstairs
oh
what
what's zero
am I in timeout
there you go good great excellent
oh there's a third
man
I don't know about this one guys
nope
I'm not even gonna try if I see a little
bit of a blue I'm I'm gonna just run
because I I'm gonna change it because I
don't I don't need to stick around for
that six is dead input six is no good
the name of the game is input six
there's something special about input
six
what is it
but what is the special thing I don't
even know what the special thing is this
looks like it could have a special thing
are you nope uh nope
nope just looks important it ain't
though don't worry it ain't
how can you get in the room if I'm
looking right at the door
[Music]
oh
God
I'm never gonna get that
no no I couldn't get me you're not gonna
get me pal I'm probably going the same
way I've been going every time with this
one but I I don't know and I don't care
what's this this looks normal new novel
looks normal and new there's got to be
something here you
freak
[Music]
oh I guess oh I guess I never could have
gotten that one okay
we're just it
oh
I don't like that
I don't like that you can stop that
you can stop that right now you can stop
that immediately
no is it
no clue not a clue not a clue hey little
office
I also think that when some of these
things get caught
it gets moved or something like that
something to that effect what
what whoa
what what is that
what is that I can't see it's too dark
what is it
what am I looking at
what was I looking at
wait
did you move me
whoa
uh no you didn't move me
oh can you get me if you got the other
two
don't get me don't get me
Dawn I'm begging you
there's nothing but there was a people
uh nope I don't know I don't understand
I don't understand what I'm looking for
I haven't seen it
I haven't seen a single thing that would
indicate what it is besides this beeping
and I can't get to the beeping
beeping
oh nice well not nice
I'm fast forwarding
somehow this is going well
so obviously in this place they were
building these things
Maids the maids some kind of helpful
thing forever your everyday life or
something like that
how's your new area every time
whoa whoa
was there a new area every time every
time it's new area it's like I'm in six
different buildings all right what
huh
oh
why
[Applause]
I'm gonna watch you because clearly I'm
not doing this right
and I may be a pile of scrap but I got a
funny feeling I might be one of you too
I might be a maid
or something of like
I just want to know what the deal is
with this
[Applause]
oh I'm
that I'm in the pile of scrap
so that's what happens that's why
it does that and I wake up in a new
place because I get high
[Music]
do I I press uh oh oh try switching the
input only when necessary the more times
you switch it the more difficult the
gameplay becomes I didn't know that so
do I
start
I guess I do
um so I don't know anything of what I'm
supposed to do here I have not found
anything of what I am seeking but I'm
gonna try this again and I hope to have
a little bit of success
all right
that that's what I'm looking for some
kind of walkie-talkie-ass thing so if I
can find that
I'm good
and if I can't
um bad okay so don't switch randomly
nope
don't like that
this one has a damaged sound recording
module that's probably why it sounds
like a night
nope
beep beep beep beep
beep
I heard a beep
I heard the beep where'd the beep go
with the beep go I heard the beep I
heard the beep
I had the beep and I gotta assume that
the beat means something
otherwise what would even be the point
of the beep
it's dead
he's definitely alerting me to something
and I got a funny feeling that is
actually going to be the thing that I'm
looking for and if it's not then what's
the point of that beep
Kansas beat for no reason how am I still
finding new places around here I don't
even know what
where am I
an amazing ass employee place was this
supposed to be anyway new record added
to Archive how do I get to the high
how do I get to the archives
how do I get to the archives Let Me In
The Archives
oh nice fast forward
I don't know if it's detrimental to fast
forward but I will Fast Forward what if
I follow the red
you think the red is like a little bit
of a clue
could be could be could be could be
could be could be
red or maybe maybe the red was just
defining that hallway over there and
wasn't doing anything for me
probably more likely but
I can be wishful thinking
you know I'm beep
I heard it
how can you just beep once
that doesn't make any sense that's not
how beeps work you're beep and then you
beep again
we beep we beep and we beep again and
live time and whatever
nope okay uh I've got the no that's fine
I got the rhythm of it like the rough
rhythm of it anyway
what kind of rhythm
Rhythm of the Night
whoa beep beep
beep
such a C4
is that just telling me this whole thing
is rigged to Blue
what good is that gonna do me if you
blow me up all with it I don't even know
what I'm looking at five
how am I gonna find this thing
fine as I
what even is that saying tell me what it
is
I wish I could read The Archives but I
cannot
now I am starting to go in circles
I can tell that in the same place
already
definitely
there's that beep again but it means
nothing
apparently
man oh she's getting a bit more
aggressive
oh my God yeah you're getting a bit more
new record oh that was something
since when was that something
whoa
how's that supposed to know that was
something there's no indication that it
is to something
I don't know when anything is to
something
[Music]
I'd probably just went in a circle again
I did well
where am I
oh
whoa whoa whoa whoa I found it
wait what but this what is there more
oh input six
what what do you mean
what do you mean but I got it but I did
it but I did the thing but I did it
but but I did it
I did it right does all of we are in
different locations aren't we oh boy oh
you have such beautiful eyes we're all
in different locations
and each of us has our own thing to find
so I found one of five
one of five alive
that's difficult
that sounds difficult
that sounds very difficult
I'm not
eyes again look I'm not I'm not I know
that switching is a bad thing and I know
that doing it more makes the game harder
and yada yada I don't know exactly how
it works
but I know that that's a general gist of
it so all of these are different looking
see I thought all of them were in the
same location I thought I was crazy like
but seems like I'm in different
buildings I am in different buildings or
I'm in different parts of the same
building rather I don't remember this
big blue pipe
and they do have explosives
oh man I've been wasting a lot of time
I would have been fast forwarding more
as soon as I said that I decided to kill
it
got it still
[Laughter]
you dumb
you is dumb
but even so even now that I kind of
understand what I'm supposed to do I
still don't know how I'm supposed to do
it
well okay that's
yeah I still don't know okay so it's
like a white box but all these things
are like white small objects of the same
size which I'm sure is the intent is the
intention and they're trying to make it
equally confusing no matter which way
you're going
and that's fine I get that
whoa
and I probably should be fast forwarding
a lot more
explodey there
go this way
hi ah man she is uh
ever present these days
she is
looking over my shoulder at every turn
this is the kind of game that you would
need to play multiple times just to be
able to get the rhythm of uh the layout
of the building
because that's well that's
you think it's giving me a clue do you
think it's given me a clue of where it
might be is it in that projector room
kind of curious about that but maybe not
probably not I think unless I wake up in
that projector room I think that
correct
oh whoa you were right there the other
challenge is sometimes the camera snaps
in a direction towards
uh the maid and um that leaves me not
going in the way that I was going and I
have to try to remember it's all about
keeping it in your memory
oh I think this is a game very much
about like just trying to Envision the
layout of it and it's usually something
that I'm good at just
getting used to it no it's not here
because I'm starting here so it's
definitely not here there's only so much
space in these but there's only so much
space here there really is not that much
space here
Mosey
[Music]
there it is oh I had it I had it I was
right there God damn you so there but
there is a green light on it there was a
green light on that one it was kind of a
green light so if I do look for that
then I should be able to see it
unless you'd be able to find it a little
easier I should be able to do whatever
the hell I came here to do
I don't know if it took that one away to
a different location but
felt like it might have
so I just got there is a green glowy on
it
oh office this is different
yeah I just I just have not made
progress ah and that's why this one is
like that because it would hide the
green light oh oh okay
there it is I did it
oh
oh you don't look so good well you've
Fallen apart
all right I'm here again I'm not here
I'm not supposed to be there I'm
supposed to be literally anywhere else
where am I where is this oh I know where
this is Just Gotta Keep It In My Memory
my big strong brain
I'm out
that is the Paper Mill area
this is how am I oh back here
again
where'd the office go
I don't remember which one had the
office in it
[Music]
I ah
all right I'm Gonna Leave This one there
it would take me a very long time to get
good enough to be able to get everything
and also become familiar enough with the
layout but I like what it's doing it was
maybe a little too nebulous but at the
same time it was spooky it's spooky it
is spooky it's an interesting new way to
do this and I like it I like it but
maybe I'm crazy maybe you guys think
differently maybe you guys are of a
different opinion maybe you think I'm
dumb maybe you think I'm wrong
well if so let me know in the comments
but if you think I'm smart and you want
me to play this again and beat it let me
know in the comments as well this is a
fun one it's different it's novel it's
Unique
I like it anyway
thank you
is that footsteps I hear right behind
you